this is its baby can I say is this too
much to say the biggest event of your
professional career
yeah such an exciting time in our lives
we put so much into this album and of
course it's been so secretive but now we
can finally talk freely about it people
are gonna be listening our fans are
gonna be listening and we're so ready
and confident for this next chapter
Elias and you know when a band puts you
know does a self-titled album sometimes
it's their debut and debut self-titled
thing that can be a thing whether it's a
solo artist or a group but when it's not
their first record and then they decide
on album three or four whenever it comes
up to do self-titled then I get I get
this sense that's a statement tell me
about that decision that you came to to
call this record fifth or well honestly
we just felt that it was the best
representation especially like you said
it's in this point in our careers right
now we've worked so hard and we just
feel like this energy and this time is
different than anything else that we've
ever done or put out especially because
we were able to be creative throughout
the process and we were heavily involved
and we just feel like we've learned to
love music again and we've definitely
gotten our power back we've learned to
love each other even more because we're
able to be in the studio and like pick
at each other's minds and like challenge
one another and we just have so much
that we have to offer that so many
people just don't even know and I think
that this will be a statement in itself
so why not call it fifth harmony yep
makes so much okay so that must have
been obviously that's important if
you're in studio together to listen to
each other yeah how easy was it for you
guys to come to consensus when you were
in studio recording putting the words
that you had written we're singing those
words and making the music and you guys
had a hand in how easy for was it for
the four of you to come together and
agree was there any kind of like no not
really we kind of did like pairs during
the writing process so like Dinah and
your money would go in
would go in or or money and I would go
in it like vice versa so we did like a
bunch of different sessions that way and
then we kind of yeah we were
experimenting with different vibes
different singer-songwriters different
people different producers and I feel
like we kind of were really on the same
page I feel throughout the whole process
creatively about what fit what we wanted
to say you know what I mean like when
like Donna and their money for example
create a song called lonely night like
when they created that song we heard it
back like Ali and I heard it back with
them in the room we were like holy this
is amazing this is for sure going on the
album you know what I mean so like in in
that regard like and that just as an
example that's how we kind of were with
each other's work and with each other
like really listening to each other's
stuff and we've interests wow that's
amazing interesting each other exactly
because we were just so on the same page
creatively about what we wanted to say I
knew where you were going you had a
similar end point exactly
but you said experimentation what a
luxury to have in studio yeah freedom to
experiment art yeah that's that's where
the art comes in right amen and that's
where the connection comes in too
because you kind of get to really pick
your own brain and pick your own heart
and and play with melodies and and play
with sounds and play with each other's
versions of that because like we've
always been given songs I'm just being
completely honest and realistic with you
and it's it's cool to not have to sit
there and try to figure out what that
song means to you and it's like I know
what the connection is I know what I'm
actually singing about and I genuinely
feel it when I'm in the booth and I
think that it's something that the
people will be able to use throughout
the records
you've talked about breaking down
borders before breaking down barriers or
anything linking down barriers with your
music and your in your group did you
break down some more such a such a
journey to get to this very moment and
I'm it's crazy because I was kind of
reflecting on it today and the fact that
our album is out everything we went
through all of our dreams and what we
wanted for ourselves has come to
fruition right now is just honestly a
breathtaking experience we're taking it
all in
we're having so much fun like this is
really the time of our lives
to be quite honest and
we're having such an incredible time
because they covered it up
we've stepped up and we've taken charge
this time around where were the captains
of the ship yeah and that's why we're so
proud and we're so excited for this new
era because we've been waiting for this
and I feel like in time you had to kind
of you know earn it you had to they'll
go out there and you have to build
yourself to have this part where you're
at right now so you guys are discovered
who you are on this journey probably
more than than before you've learned a
lot about each other you're empowering
your fans you're empowering the people
who love your music
thank you while you're doing and I'm
just thinking what a great what a great
week you're performing on the video
video well yeah yeah later tonight at
midnight which is just crazy like like
role models for young women and people
in general out there to kind of have and
they've got you guys right now which is
so good and the word empowering comes up
a lot when I talk to people about you
guys
you obviously know that there's a little
bit of responsibility that comes with a
position that you're in and it's fun and
it's great and I want to be a part of
your gang already but you guys do you
feel that that responsibility that
you've got there do you realize that
there are people who have grown up yes I
kind of with you and followed your
journey and now more inspired by where
you are today it's cool that you touch
on the fact that our fans and us have
definitely grown up together like we did
a signing at Hard Rock Cafe I think it
was in like the bay area and we've seen
some of the same fans like at absolutely
we've met when they were babies like we
can say that
they grew up together and they were all
like graduating from college like yeah
and it's incredible to just like having
those people come to us and knowing
where they came from at the beginning
like knowing that they were in a place
of because in the beginning we had a lot
of people coming to us of talking about
things like self harm and self-hatred
and and suicidal thoughts and stuff like
that I remember we got a ton of that in
the beginning and to see those same
people come back to us as many years
later and be like you're the reason I
love myself you're the reason that I got
out of that you're the reason that I'm
clean you're the reason I'm going to
school you're the reason I'm doing this
that those kind of things are so
powerful and so special to us because
all of the us and the people the type of
people that we are like that's what
matters to us in this whole process
we're artists and we love making music
but also we're like genuine people all
of us and we love to make people happy
and we love making people feel loved and
to love themselves and to feel important
so that is the greatest gift that we
could possibly have done so that and
another one is a number one yeah ever
take that away from you you have that
forever you have a number one number one
debut right yeah did we yeah yeah he's
speaking it into exist oh I'm so we're
speaking I'm in the single angel now
we're speaking names
for my lips to God's ears for sure I
give you number one on the time did you
where were you when you found out about
that other than right here apparently we
were in Mexico and dancing just the text
without your image in Mexico
yes our manager sent us the text message
we were like I mean it's just and it's
all so I'm kind of low-key super happy
also that it happened with angel it's
moments like ring we love that song and
we knew that it would we knew it we knew
it we knew that people were going to
because we were able to pick and choose
what was the best fit for this album
that was like the best representation of
the direction we were trying to go at
this time around so for that to come out
first we were like this is game-changer
this groundbreaking and this is stepping
into the new fifth harmony and this is
who we've been all the time in it it was
a we wanted to also release it like cuz
down was the first of all we put out so
then this one coming out we wanted to
show the range of what this album is
gonna touch upon you know anybody but my
favorites yet yeah there's still way
knowing and so knob down nominated for a
song of the summer
that's right and then a number-one debut
right we're gonna put some all of these
things are kind of happening in order
the plane is being executed I always
believed in us and I believe something
so magical and special together and so
big bigger than what we could describe
and now just seeing it happen is like I
just think it's you're crazy it's just
so special like nobody knows what we
went through and we're here and we're
being successful we're rising together
and we have a sisterhood and we have our
story and our journey and people thank
you to everybody who supported us cuz
you're making a biggest dream yet this
is not vulnerable what a wonderful what
a wonderful thing though for all the
hard work that you've put in for the
music to be being received as positively
as it is right now that's the you can
exhale good place like our hearts and
our mentalities and our spirits like
we're all so happy right now I'm like
together and and just individually to
like we're just in such an amazing space
so it's really it's really gratifying
like you said like just to have worked
and been through what we did in the
fresh you know that it there was the
light at the end of the tunnel you know
even if we didn't recognize even if we
does it everyone around us always told
us everything's gonna be okay yeah yeah
can you sense that that that that hunger
for your music and you know that people
are so excited to get their hands on
your record
oh they're dying to like everyone who's
interviewed us has also been great like
they're just like I feel I feel the
hunger for like new material and like
what we're talking about people interest
rate it was a shock it was a I know you
guys had had teased the video yeah and
and then Taylor was teasing her stuff
not to bring him just back to Taylor but
it seemed to me like if I was at you
know as a fan of music I get to spend
the weekend with fifth harmony nothing
but digest great music by strong women
love that like as a as a man speaking to
us radiates very like love that that's
really it just feels like very healthy
and balanced to me I appreciate that
we're so super really appreciate that
credible women are villainous